there's not one by me anymore what does
this stand for here everything's better
really yeah that doesn't really it's
like a phrase it's like naming your
store
hold your horses hold your horses
Outpost yeah here everything's better
why does it look crooked it does look
crooked
[Music]
yeah
is that better it looks better
any adjustments more towards my
Direction no let's see I think uh try
sitting down I think you'll be good sit
down and sit in the sit in the back of
your chair and that'll be your that'll
be your limit like I'm good
so you gotta yeah
hell yeah hell yeah brother so I think
it's working
what do you think about uh can we do
that there we go okay
what do you think about the other
people's show that we've been doing man
I'm excited the growth that it's done I
mean yeah it seems consistent you know
we have more weeks that are uh good than
not you know which it was mean we've
I've done like no marketing for it and
it keeps on getting people to come out
so that's cool
yeah uh no it's exciting man it's like
your little baby you know yeah we've
been doing it forever yeah I've been
doing it with you for almost a year now
yeah and then how long were you doing it
before then
I don't know it seems like we've been
doing it together the whole time mostly
yeah yeah thanks for doing it that's
very nice yeah man no worries I I enjoy
it I think it's cool uh and I like you
know qual like production is just
something that's always interested me
yeah like fiddling behind the scenes
yeah to make people look good well not
yeah in a sense like you know rather I'd
rather get it set up like if we had a
permanent like setup and just come in
and turn the lights on so I guess set
yeah that would be but have you thought
about moving to a different venue no not
really why Vulcan I don't know man I was
thinking about that I don't know what
would we move to
I thought about this at first I was
saying like Paramount but also I don't
think Paramount would do the same
what's the Paramount that theater
man I wish I didn't make these this
chicken because now we started the
podcast already we can't eat it it's
just a set decoration it's just evenly
placed in the middle I already had one
it was delicious I'm gonna have one you
should do it you should you should do it
with a fork though resist your Asian
you guys I can't believe you got that at
HEB just like in the cold section or
what yeah Frozen
bro that's bomb
here everything's better HEB if you
don't live in Texas how long you haven't
been in Texas that long
um I left California
March the year of the pandemic when it
started uh no way that's really early
yeah I was I didn't even I was still
paying my lease
um I just got the [ __ ] out of there they
started shutting down I thought it was
weird
um because everyone you know obviously
no one knew what was going on but they
started shutting down the first things
to go in La were the comedy clubs the
the nightclubs and the restaurants held
on as long as they could
but the comedy clubs were like yeah
we're not necessary sorry we even tried
dude yeah once like The Comedy Store
shut down and stuff like that I was like
that's that's weird right I mean that's
yeah it's like that's like not sign of
the Apocalypse Kinda Yeah there's no
humor no laughter anymore yeah sadness
only we will die together sad why did
you do an Asian accent we will die
together sad oh I don't even know what
that
that's like a yeah that's my knockout
Japanese I think I think that's what you
know I'm from Alabama so we
Alabama we don't always get it right
but I moved to Austin uh a year after I
moved to Texas I went I moved in with my
parents first because they live up by
Dallas and they have they live in like
the county so they have like a little
bit of land
and um so you were here before Joe Rogan
you just moved here because you left
Texas yeah it was a safe space you know
not if you're
a Mexican yeah arguably there's a lot of
uh you know
development going on Mexican development
job security is is rampant right a lot
of breasts growing in Mexican breasts
growing in
Texas
I think Mexicans have better better
breast milk
yeah it's like they're Coca-Cola it's
got real sugar in it yeah high fructose
orange juice I think it's got cocaine in
it too
I think that's just the Colombians uh
Colombian breast milk would you if they
brought Coca-Cola
well I don't know if they would bring it
back but if there was a 1920s Coca-Cola
with cocaine in it the original formula
right here would you try it or do you
think it's too far gone I mean it's over
October so no yeah okay in November
would you it's remember remember
November
remember November what's that one it's
where you can't do any memory loss drugs
oh okay you have to only do speed
I uh I thought it was No Shave November
that's what I always always told that's
fun yeah just No Shave no one can tell
when I'm doing no shade November I have
Apache beard too man yeah I can get this
I get like a little Landing Strip it's
all I can do nice we got a little neck
[ __ ] A Little Neck [ __ ] little wolf
beard you know a little wolf puss yeah
but no cheeks I got spotted yeah I got
one spot right here on my cheek yeah and
then this doesn't connect to this I mean
maybe it does now spot yeah yeah we got
similar facial hair yeah maybe I'm Asian
maybe you have that too much estrogen
yeah I'm a soy boy drink too much soy
milk huh is that the yeah that's what
they say are you politically liberal you
know I don't really know
um where I like where I land what do you
pay attention to most
I mean
I just read like I I use this app called
smart news and it's just literally
unbiased articles every angle every you
know so I just read whatever sounds
captivating and I kind of like
checks yeah maybe yeah like I go to an
app the app tells me what to think tells
me exactly each day it's a new spot
but I mean I'm not like you know like I
think like the abortion [ __ ] like I I
just don't know like I I don't have a
real opinion other than like why are we
[ __ ] canceling
you know abortions and like yeah like
there's not even in a gray area anymore
they're not they're like you were raped
and you are pregnant well you got
Jeffrey Dahmer's baby now it's like why
what like yeah we shouldn't procreate
and spread Bad Seed we should uh be a
little more diligent maybe like a um
maybe like a license to breed kind of
like how you have to get a license to
drive yeah like you have to be certainly
educated
so how would you prevent people from
having babies hmm maybe you like
what's the what's the easiest to reverse
a vasectomy or tubes tied I think of
vasectomy so maybe we just give all boys
when you you know when you cut the
foreskin you also cut the snip snip yeah
from Burger Snips two steps yeah the
head and the the two birds
yeah yeah I mean we could vasectomy
everybody I mean I just think that uh
having people have babies when they want
it is a good good way to do it it's been
working
do you think that
um education system though has something
to do with like contributing to the like
uh
I don't even know how to articulate it
but like
so like you have more babies if you're
Dumber well I think that's the trend
yeah typically like in Alabama or like
West Virginia is what I I think about a
lot there's yeah because you're from
Alabama yeah we don't like to like to
push the blame yeah most people that are
dumb and more babies like here like here
don't look here but look up there yeah
have you seen this documentary called
the Wild and wonderful Whites of West
Virginia [ __ ] wild a little bit yeah
you should see the whole thing if you
haven't uh but that's that's my example
like that's what I reference like when I
think of that it's like because they
they're literal like
they have babies to get more welfare
money
like that's their MO
right but I mean how do you know you're
making more money overall
I don't think they're making much I
don't think they're making much I just
think they're making enough to get by I
mean I think it's natural I think it's a
combination of welfare and also this is
like the way that they're programmed
they're like for sure kids and then if
you're a dad then you have more meaning
and significance if you're just like a
West Virginian then you're just like you
know just a loser but if you have a kid
yeah you're like I have a son I'm a
father and I have a seed yeah it's like
you're you're you're more valuable
yeah also if you have Oxycontin I think
you're pretty valuable in West Virginia
too they say that's the mating call if
you watch the documentary yeah he shakes
the bottle a lot of people talk about it
I've never done Oxycontin have you no
I'm not into like I'm not into pills
really at all but who picks Oxycontin
oxy slaves I don't get the reference you
know black people black oxy blacks
wasn't oxyblack
it's like a black person that picks
Oxycontin you know what I was thinking
I just watched the Jeffrey Dahmer
documentary of course he did and uh is
it a documentary or is it a show it's
like a show yeah but it's supposed to be
pretty accurate like even the the room
his room that the the set that they made
like the set design it's to the T of the
same crime photos like the aquarium
there's like a rolled up rug by the
couch it's like the same carpet the same
wall art the 70s yeah to a t so that's
kind of eerie they take pictures of it
yeah the crime scene right but they but
the one thing I learned from that
documentary is don't take a drink that
someone else makes you and that's how I
did it that's how he did it yeah he just
you didn't learn that lesson very well I
thought about it
I'm live streaming we're live if uh
Halcyon I guess is is done tell them my
address yeah [ __ ] paranoid
um 312 East Martin Luther King Jr
Boulevard yeah I live with the blacks
yeah that's a that's a
I did it I've been doing these like
brand ambassador gigs on the weekends
sometimes for uh Corona
I think for the virus uh for the beer
and um
it's a tailgate basically I get paid to
go just
hell yeah yeah like slurms MacKenzie
from Futurama oh I'm a sellout dude I'm
like hey you guys want to party I'm a
commercially you're like a pop-up ad
yeah What a Sad life that guy had though
he hated it
from Futurama yeah yeah he was partying
forever yeah when you're partying
forever you're never partying you think
that's how it goes or do you think
you're just
I don't know I had heard that vape and
rape vaping right dude
um I think that if you party too much
then you have nothing to compare it to
and then you're you need to you need to
do something to party if you're just
partying that's not partying yeah that
you don't you need something to
associate it with yeah you need to be
celebrating something right that should
be it like uh uh like a like a uh you
know like an end of the year rap party
you don't just do that celebrate your
your accomplishments for the year type
of thing yeah have a real reason yeah
that makes sense I've been feeling like
that more the older I get we're the same
well we're almost the same age I turn 33
next Saturday October 8th you're still
young man I got a lot of life ahead of
you we both do but I'm saying like the
drinking aspect of like going out and
partying and and it you know drinking is
like such a dumb drug
it takes a lot of it and it makes you
feel horrible
for real especially like hangovers
nowadays dude yeah we're still doing
drugs that they did in the 1200s yeah
well like they were drinking like Mead
between the 1200s have you ever had meat
no it's [ __ ] terrible yeah we should
do meat one day and see what the
hangover is like see if we burn any
witches oh my God yeah just wake up
miserable and misogynistic yeah we'll
just [ __ ] have a Witch Hunt in Austin
it won't be hard to find them
yeah just get a net and go to a bike
trail yeah just have like a broom empty
brooms just like laying on the trail and
whoever picks it up
gotcha yeah it's a Mexican janitor
trying to clean up just trying to
[ __ ] tidy up man with her breast milk
her
real sugar BM
yeah it's all back call back baby call
back culture I'm gonna go for another
one of these hell yeah
well you do that I'll I don't know I
almost made it worse
um so let's see
sharing that Chinese food the van is
looking good inside this is not the van
I think it's a little tilted towards my
oh no it's not it's pretty good
I mean yeah it's good I mean I'm not
going back this far yeah it just looks a
little
tilted
um
it is a little bit your side is more
down my side is more of the other head
space right you're talking yeah
but uh yeah I like that the little sound
board is in the shot makes it look like
it's a real podcast
this is new huh or how long have you had
this
uh I've had it for a little bit but
that's so stupid it's like a hundred
bucks and there's no way to connect
headphones multiple headphones to the
soundboard you can only connect one at a
time that's how they get you yeah I have
an interface that was like 1200 bucks uh
and it has room for two channels so two
mics
um
but only one headphone
so like you're required to get an eight
channel which I assume is what this is
uh yeah that's what they say it is but I
think you need a
double up on one channel two channels
yeah I don't know much about they say
that it's eight channels at a certain
frequency and then four channels that
but I think that has the
deal with more like live instruments and
recording like you need more power for
like a electric guitar yeah this is way
overpowered for what we're doing
it's cool though you have a
I thought you had like a compression um
compression is like I wonder if it's on
here I haven't really fooled with your
board too much it's always really dark
in the cave when we look at it but
there's a there's a on some of them they
have this like compression and limiter
so like if someone yells in the mic or
drops the mic and it makes that pop
sound it won't translate onto the
yeah that's important
yeah sounds been getting better though
since we've had Dylan
consistently you know we figured out
um something yesterday with the audio
default
is the setting in OBS yeah that's for
audio it comes up on default well it
doesn't it was coming up on like a game
channel or something like that and uh it
is game channel for the video but it's
default for the audio so anyway that's
what that was [ __ ] you think the audio
here is good I haven't been checking
I mean it sounds cool it's yeah I think
it's working so yeah I mean for this one
I did like the USB codec
okay anyways yeah what do you think
about like
the crowd yesterday
I thought the crowd yesterday was weird
yeah but it was a crowd though there was
like 25 people it was a critical mass
there yeah yeah there was a good amount
that family from West Virginia or
wherever they were that uh yeah I was
like don't talk about my mom's sexual
stuff yeah you had a dating show yeah
dude the parents were the coolest people
yeah the parents are way cooler than the
sun yeah the sun sucked I don't know who
you are dude crap you got some general
sauce on your shirt oh man
you want to look at the offer
I feel bad but it's really not my fault
I did it that's my it's my second
favorite yeah it's all right
yes that's the shirt it matches my uh
shorts matches your nipples yeah I do
you see those bad boys
I got it I always have like nipples on
display dude I don't know why we got
those kind of nipples are they dark or
are they no they're like textual we'll
show this they're they're you know what
I heard your lip your lips are the same
color as your
the nibbles so if you want to know what
someone's nipple color is you just look
at their lips okay because it's the same
skin
I haven't done too much I haven't done
too much research on this but a couple
of people that's a good pickup line yeah
how would you use it in a did you know
that your lens on the same color as your
nipples yeah let me show you now let me
see yours yeah now let me know we need a
bigger sample size your turn yeah
where's where's your friends
scientifically this is inconclusive yeah
maybe I just said that because it's true
for me but maybe it's true for you too
what do you think would be the exception
someone without
I don't know that it's completely wrong
and some people have dark nipples and
they don't have dark
lips
like who has you know those dark nipples
let's pull up some pictures dude
awesome no lips anyways so what do you
think about like the comedy scene in
Austin it's kind of kicking off yeah man
it's been kicking off uh
steadily since I've gotten here and it
just seems like now it's becoming more
taken serious like it was yeah it's like
a [ __ ] grind now it's like okay let's
get to work people are stopping by more
like bigger names are are making an
effort to put this on their tour
schedule so to speak
yeah Nick Swardson was here David tell
and like Austin's not that big of a city
and I'm sure they were coming here
before but now it's like I think it's
even more now and now it's like oh Joe
Rogan's podcast a lot of those people
that come here for his podcast
uh and now Cap City is another reason
and they're like oh let's go to Cap City
Joe Rogan's there and then kill Tony's
there and to hang and it's like a new
thing we're creating a new scene instead
of the old scene and you just have to
ingratiate yourself into the old scene
this is a new scene
and you get to make it your own right do
you think we're getting a new Comedy
Store like Yeah Joe Rogan's Club is you
think that's gonna be it I mean well
like that's what he's modeling it after
[ __ ] yeah yeah
I think a lot of people don't like
I mean some big name comedians don't
like me and like I think some of my
jokes suck and I I don't like my ACT
sometimes so I get it but I think some
of it is that they don't like that I
came up through
uh outside the system they're like they
came up through the system
LA and like ingratiating themselves at
that and they don't respect anyone who
hasn't done it their way but you know
comedy's comedy right if you can make an
audience laugh that's really the metric
so you don't have to be in New York or
L.A comedy audiences are everywhere
that's kind of like I think in most jobs
though too like you got these people who
have been like a pool cleaner for
example I've been cleaning pools for 20
years and this new guy just joined the
job and he's making the same money as
I'm making yeah it's good to have that
because then you maintain quality if you
just let everyone in without thinking or
without critical analysis then you're
just gonna have a lower quality product
saturated yeah yeah so it's good that
it's hard and yeah giving me [ __ ] and
they're not giving me the respect that I
deserve well that's a good thing too
that you're being talked about even
negative right I mean yeah like Alex
Jones
dude he was a
that's he's a character man yeah I mean
he was great
uh he went it was like silly and fun and
Goofy yeah and I think it kind of took a
dark turn because like people really
took him seriously when he said that
Sandy Hook thing and then like people
were like torturing these poor families
it's like how dare you have a kid die
horribly right how dare you like they
were calling him actors and stuff right
yeah what do you think do you think that
was his real
like take on it straightforward or do
you think it got muddied through I think
it's a little bit of column a little bit
of column B yeah who knows like a heart
part of it's like wouldn't it be funny
if this is all fake see yeah I wonder
how it started it had to be like right I
mean why would you but then it's like he
did it for every shooting every shooting
it was like this is fake this is fake
um and yeah I mean I just think uh
it's like it's like fun and it's like
not logical or like evidence-based
anymore it's more like feeling based and
it's like what is the funnest take I can
have on this and he's doing it online
he's doing it for an audience so he
needs to make it entertaining yeah but
where do you do you is there a line do
you think in that I think the line is
based on evidence right like if there is
some evidence that it was fake then yeah
like you should say it but if there's no
evidence and it's a horrible thing yeah
the juice isn't worth the squeeze does
he have any evidence that he claims well
no because it was real it didn't happen
yeah yeah well I mean according to the
mainstream media well I I just don't
know why it wouldn't you know
it's just one of those delicacy like
things like if it it's like you the
families are already traumatized right
your child your Elementary it's like if
you're wrong like it's so bad it's so so
bad yeah yeah and if you're right it's
like what do you win really yeah you're
the it's like you're making fun of an
actor that got paid like yeah whatever
yeah I'm fine with it you can hassle me
yeah
what if they were all actors though
it's fun you know it's like
see this is the approach that I think it
had to have come from because it is
funny to say what if but like he was
aggressively like yeah no it is and it's
like well I heard that it's because he
started selling those pills
and then he became like a business and
it became about the money it wasn't
about the ideas and having fun anymore
it was like about
uh just content yeah just yeah
maximizing profit yeah just in a
whatever way yeah
I don't know there's something to like I
don't want to ever get big off of like
that kind of content I would rather
torturing victims of school shootings
you just like well yeah but I mean like
just like like pretending to know things
right like presenting information or
entertainment as fact yeah because you
have to be accountable like yeah what
you say So eventually you're gonna have
to have that conversation with somebody
it's like once you put that out into the
world it's like you're just opening
yourself up for those conversations and
and when they happen you can't run away
from them you have to have them yeah
that's why it's good to be a comedian
because it's like we're not here to
spread information we're here for the
emotional catharsis right but like me I
don't really do that thing where I'm
like what about a unicorn [ __ ] a
bunny rabbit yeah like improv exercises
all the time and always riffing and
stuff I'd like to be more evidence-based
and like talk about reality and facts
over entertainment and fun which some
people think is boring well when you can
Loop it in and make it work which you do
a good job of it I think it's brilliant
like it's the same thing as like crowd
work like like when you're doing when
you're talking about real [ __ ] or
something that's tangible something
that's right in front of you it's
totally different than just your what
ifs yeah because like it's further and
far between but it's like when it hit
it's it's Stronger Yeah and it resonates
longer too because it's like uh
actionable it's like you can take that
into your real life yeah you can and
then you could like that's your memory
too like I remember before you know uh
Andrew
um Tate no Andrew Schultz Jesus uh I was
a big fan of him from his crowd work
before he did his like you know before
he did all his [ __ ] and uh it was on
Tech talk yeah he was talking about his
algorithm that got him blown up he was
posting before he blew up he was posting
just his whole sets and then he went to
posting two to three minute clips of
just outtakes and then he found that
people were staying on his page longer
for up to an hour and a half even versus
if he would put out an hour and a half
One Clip people would only watch nine
minutes or less yeah because it's
daunting yeah you're like I'm stuck here
but if you just got three minutes you're
like [ __ ] I can it's the best of yeah
show me the best part of your set yeah I
don't want to sit through hey how you
doing everyone's settling yeah what's
your job and he does so much crowd work
that there's really not a lot of setup
needed for those clips which I think is
um what's so captivating on on his
approach yeah
but yeah I mean he's found a way to
Market himself or like clip himself or
edit himself into being interesting for
a large audience
so that's what you want to do it's crowd
work I do appreciate crowd work yeah I
like crowd work
um also like you know storytelling and
stuff but like
tangible [ __ ] like something that like
you know experiences like like you said
not the Unicorn [ __ ] a bunny but like
Chestnut yeah uh but yeah I think crowd
works good I think you also can't do
crowd work at like an open mic yeah you
know it doesn't work the same yeah
because the audience doesn't want it but
if everyone's amped up and they're
excited to be there that's all you need
to like have like a lot of like sets in
front of great audiences to get good at
that stuff
agreed yeah it's the uh the catch-22.
but Chris Reese is good at it and he
does it at open mics too yeah Chris
Reese is good are you talking about the
yeah I know you're talking about the
curly hair long hair fat bigger guy yeah
yeah he's like he doesn't care he
doesn't give a [ __ ] to the core which is
something that I respect if you cared
yeah I don't know how he does it but
yeah he's just like so relaxed
when he does that his mind is free is is
it's not all tight and constricted with
fear and anxiety he's like what do you
do yeah yeah why not yeah and if it
sucks he just moves on like no I got
nothing for that yeah it was just funny
in itself but yeah there's always a
funny way a funny angle no matter what
you do and that's a great place to be
when you're in the zone like that
yeah I did uh I did some crowd work I
did um Brian mcduffie's mic and Round
Rock and uh that's a good show I don't
know if you've ever done that one yeah
but uh yeah that's funny is uh if you're
like yeah I did this uh crowd work show
so that's not a crowd work show that's
my show yeah you're supposed to do your
best stuff yeah I did I did some stuff
but uh I had 15 minutes and I I just
started off with uh yeah that's sort of
your Vibe you're a very like
affectionate amicable
hi guys yeah you think that works
I don't know I haven't seen you go out
yeah but yeah I mean I'm sure that it
works and sometimes it doesn't but if
you if that's who you are and then
you're gonna stick with it and get
better and better at it
do you think like you hit on girls too
much sometimes
um
I
know
well you're just like a such a likable
guy that sometimes like yeah I
definitely embrace it if I'm getting
attention like I don't shy from it but
like
um yeah like sometimes like you know if
I'm feeling good
I'll just be on a roll and then women
will start talking to me and then just
like I just don't stop it yeah why would
you yeah I mean I think women enjoy
your smile yeah seem very relaxed and
happy and stuff yeah I think that's true
also I do know where the line is like I
won't [ __ ] your wife unless you unless
you want me to
and then uh
you know then there's more rules but
like you know I don't know I out of the
bar having fun I mean
think it's all fair game
conversationally
yeah
yeah it's a wild west out there yeah but
it's like yeah it's like there are no
rules and like yeah you shouldn't get
attached to one person and be like
that's just my girl I'm a Founder
because that's weird if she just met a
girl and then you're like you're mine
you can't talk to anyone else that's
kind of a bad vibes but yeah it reads
wrong too and even though if you feel
that way I think it's natural to feel
that way but also
uh you know yeah it's boring it's
constricting yeah you're like oh I have
to be with this guy now even though he's
boring like there has to be this element
of I could leave at any moment and
you're like oh [ __ ] well what about that
isn't that funny that wallpaper looks
like
uh unicorn [ __ ] funny there we go
recall uh yeah yeah uh you uh but how
much of that is fake
the interaction yeah like how much of it
is just you trying to get laid versus
how much of it is like you actually
interested in actually observing and
actually noticing things well
I do have like I'm a sucker for like
entertaining like if I'm getting laughs
I'll just keep going yeah like if
there's one or two people that's enough
as long as like you know they just won't
stop yeah someone else do it well I will
you know I like riffin but like I just
uh
that that feeds me to keep going I guess
otherwise you like it I could be shy do
you think it comes from childhood
maybe I'm an only child yeah and you're
like entertaining your parents
I was grounded a lot so my mom used to
tell me I was her best friend you're my
best friend this week you're grounded oh
[ __ ] that's kind of sweet yeah it's kind
of you're not going to crash too you're
my teddy bear yeah I'm your [ __ ] wall
art
so that's cool you're like trying to
make it a worthwhile experience yeah
are you an only child no how many
siblings do you have two older younger
younger I'm the oldest
yeah everyone thinks I'm an only child
because I'm very closed off and I don't
need other people and yeah I'm asocial
and autistic
do you uh do your siblings do comedy or
any kind of entertaining
um
they're good they don't entertain good
little accountants or yeah pretty much
they're good Asians you're so you're the
least favorite
I don't know
you'd have to ask my parents I haven't
talked to them in a while I should call
them
but uh what do you think about the uh
border crisis do you think we should
open up the borders or do you think we
should close it down and
send Mexicans back
no I don't think we should send anybody
back I just think we should uh
in like I heard this example
um of like what of it being put and it
kind of resonated with me and it was a
someone said
it's like inviting someone into your
house you don't want them to hop over
your back fence you want them to come
through the front door yeah which is the
Good Vibes yeah it's like it's not that
you're not allowed to end it's just that
you're not allowed to break in well I
think it's like a a symptom of a problem
and the problem is U.S and hegemony
yeah well all the countries that they're
coming from are countries that we [ __ ]
with like what are what's what's the
correlation there yeah which I mean
which is why we shouldn't say no but
also like
we should accept a couple like we should
accept a couple thousand but like to
just be like no zero yeah and then they
have to hop over and then like what it's
their choice their choice is to live and
have their kids be risking death and
[ __ ] or they could just hop over this
border yeah it makes sense for them have
you seen those videos though of like uh
people going around the fence like like
the video will start of uh like this
white guy it's like how to climb the
fence and he literally climbs the fence
and then he jumps over and he's like
[ __ ] I forgot my backpack and then the
camera pans and he walks around the
fence and grabs it and walks back around
it's like a tech talk sketch yeah
Instagram or something but okay I just
think that like the the whole
when you talk about the border and like
immigrants coming in or or whatever uh
why we always default to the wall like
the wall is stupid like I don't
understand yeah like that's not
primitive it's futile it's not keeping
anybody out yeah it's literally it makes
it feels good yeah but it doesn't work
so like it's like a it's horrible
temporary is this what you want your
country to be is like this walled thing
that's like a fortress and you're like
spiky and gross it's like that's our
exterior that's like our skin and you
want to be like all utilitarian like the
fact that you need that is not good
um and I think like overall we just need
to make sure other countries are doing
good if Nicaragua was doing great people
wouldn't want to come here right they
don't want to go to a country where they
don't speak the language and [ __ ] where
it's not their country they'd rather
stay in Nicaragua and make Nicaragua
awesome but if we like depose their
[ __ ] president and put in chiquitas
bananas plantations all over the place
yeah so I mean it's not even our fault
anymore like we have no interest in that
[ __ ] hopefully I don't actually have no
idea but that all this [ __ ] happened
like 50 40 years ago and we just have to
deal with it it's hard do you think that
I have a theory on going back to the
Border stuff and uh even expanding that
a little bit to marijuana being still
crazily hard to come by like even
medically you can't you can't get it for
like in Texas you can only get it for
like cancer like oh there's like only
two or three ways you can be approved
like epilepsy is not one like how like
you know every other city is like our
state like California you can get it for
anxiety you can get a medical card but
yeah but anyway my going back I think it
like
the politicians right I mean the cartels
had to line their pockets and like
make some like
deal like hey and I feel like having the
old politicians still in I don't think
anything's going to change for like a
lot of
I mean I think like illegal immigration
is like 0.05 of the population that we
have I don't think it's a big deal I
think it's just like a
you know it's a fun thing to talk about
people are like oh they're coming in
yeah we got to keep it from coming in
that's good yeah yeah it's fun to talk
about but I think overall it's just like
we we just got to make sure the whole
world is doing good but then if we start
doing that we would be like well what
about Compton or Detroit or Like Flint
then we'd have to be like oh yeah we
have to work on that too and it's like
we don't want to address that
and [ __ ] so it's just like I don't know
how would you address that internally
like gentrify it like what do you
um what do you do I would say uh first
fix the infrastructure make sure
everyone can transport themselves and
live comfortably and have food right and
then everything also figure itself out
that's fair as long as people can live
safety yeah safely live safely transport
yeah yeah get to work have a good home
and make sure like that should be a
given like you shouldn't have anyone
growing up in a
and like a food desert ghetto and it's
like bulldozed and highways giant
highways everywhere I think
um as long as people
are have clean water you know like Flint
doesn't have clean water like that
should be a priority do you think they
still don't have clean water yeah I
think it's still a little [ __ ] I know
Mississippi doesn't have a lot of good
water right now like recently they went
through something I heard about that
like don't drink the tap water you'll
[ __ ] yourself something like that or
like in Hawaii the jet fuel is leaking
into the ground oh [ __ ] and some people
get cancer and [ __ ] when I was in the
Navy we stopped by uh Hawaii a couple
times at the end of our deployments I
was attached to aircraft carrier so uh
you know when we were deployed we'd come
back and then
um before we pulled back into San Diego
we'd stop by Hawaii and I remember one
time
um
it was like the Fourth of July weekend
and I was uh on this beach and my cousin
was living there at the time and he took
me to this party and
I just got bashed for being in the
military and in the Navy and blamed for
the whales dying they were like in
Hawaii yeah they were like not having it
ooh like the Hawaiians or the whites
both and I think at a bar no we were
just on the beach and there was like a
like a
awning tent in this like DJ no-name DJ
playing on the was he on a mic Rusty no
he wasn't on a mic he just had a couple
PA speakers and
so people would just come up to you and
my cousin knew some people and he was
introducing me and they're like what are
you doing I was like I'm in the military
and they're like
the military and I was like yeah and
then they were like you know you're
killing the whales and I was like I'm
not killing the whales but like that was
the vibe the rest it was uncomfortable I
didn't have a good time yeah they just
didn't like the organization you're a
part of yeah yeah which is like
yeah I mean that that's seems like you
know that's America's rap on a lot of
things it's like we try to
get involved and do better and I don't
even know if we're always doing better
but we're going to get criticized good
or bad I think someone's going to have
something to say well I think
um yeah the military
um yeah it's weird because like have you
heard that Louis CK joke about uh like a
soldier coming in and he's sitting in
first class and the soldier has to go in
the back and he's like
he thinks he's doing the right thing
he's not but he thinks he is and that's
good enough like you are trying to do
the right thing and you're you know uh
potentially going to make the ultimate
sacrifice for it
and you're getting [ __ ] on for it but
like your intentions are good it's just
right
maybe not the right way to address it
like to you to be like you're killing
the whales yeah this is kind of a funny
it's such a cliche yeah to be like the
whales think about the words the whales
that's they were [ __ ] grilling me
dude I was like I don't even know do
they grow Japanese people I don't know
like I saw you I saw the Cove I saw this
uh interaction in Hawaii and uh this
this uh white guy held the door for this
Asian guy and um he walked by and he
said thank you and he said you better
not be talking about Pearl Harbor
[ __ ]
wait the white guy said both of those
things no the Asian guy said Thank you
and then yeah the white guy said what he
said the Asian guys
the Asian guy was it's a joke it didn't
land well I don't know who said what the
Asian guy said thank you uh that's the
white guy that held the door for him and
then he said you better thank you thank
you oh okay because he was talking about
sinking the ships yeah yeah I was
walking in like a Dave and Buster's and
some employee there was like konichiwa
did you go with it or no I was like
don't do that that's racist man that's
racist yeah that's kind of being a Karen
did you bash him
over the head with your chopsticks
oh yeah I wrapped him over the head I
picked him up that's my Chopsticks have
you ever used a chopstick as a weapon or
like a no like a throwing knife
do you think they would throw well like
a metal one no
like a dart yeah
no I don't think so
darts are heavy at the tip right
and the end is like the fins yeah
they're like heavy I think like just
behind the tip yeah and then in the
front area yeah the front half yeah not
the Caboose I went ax throwing have you
been ax throwing not yet how'd you like
it it was fun it was a lot of fun it's a
skill you know as long as there's a
forward progression anything you can get
good at anything but it's like all about
the distance that you're away okay so if
you're like half a step away from the
ideal distance then it's gonna just hit
like and fall but if you it so it's like
yeah they've measured out the correct
distance where it'll spin so you up for
Success yeah and it's up to you to they
can lead you to the water but yeah you
gotta drink it but it's like what if
someone is running at me and they're
like oh this is a distance they know so
they like skip over that distance yeah
do a little side step yeah on you you're
[ __ ] would you I think it'd be better
to hold the ax at that point yeah
just like
yeah blind ly swipe like on Tinder
hell yeah you ever you ever get on
Tinder no later anymore I have a
girlfriend but yeah
um even before I had a girlfriend I
that's just not my dance yeah it's weird
I'm not a look I'm not a Luxe guy I'm
more of like uh let me trick you a
little bit yeah let me let me woo you
and then [ __ ] attack yeah but I mean
the chances of success aren't that high
but it's worth it I think overall I just
don't like the idea of it and I don't
like opening myself up to these people
yeah because I don't know I uh I I I I
don't think like women are perfect and I
think like I look at them the same way
as men and like just people in general
I'm like I don't trust your energy I
don't trust your intentions and like
I've been shitty to women just not even
trying to be like I went on a date with
this girl and I was like oh this is not
going to happen I'm not attracted to her
she's fat and then I just stood there
and she knew that I wasn't attracted to
her so it's just like
she it was definitely not worth it for
her right and I don't know it's weird I
don't want to hurt right well it's weird
though like I'm not good at the online
dating because like it's you can't
figure out the phone yeah your fingers
are too fat I still got the old flip
phone uh no but like introducing
yourself like what do you say you know
you're on a flip phone dude that'd be
gangster I don't know I'd be that should
be in your description uh eight-bit
pictures yeah pixelated you think that
would no that wouldn't work this pixel
is my boob yeah it's the same color as
my lips yeah
that's funny uh yeah I just don't have
good luck on the dating apps either
um just never like the first thing you
say also I think it's too many options
right yeah like you can just find
something very cool it's unnatural I
feel like relationships should be like
organic and it shouldn't be like I'm
horny let's go to the horny button yeah
press the horny button do you think that
that would be 60 do you think there's a
way to make that successful yeah a lot
of people do it like grinder is pretty
much that from what I understand it's
like dudes are just like hey let's just
go cut to the point gay people's hookup
app is uh grinder and then the r hook
straight people's hookup app is their
relationship app yeah but it's not the
same they want to like
talk and then ghost you and then well
everyone has different uh needs and
things that they want also true to
another thing too is like have you ever
back when you were on the dating apps
you ever like swiped and you've been
like horny and then you like you're in
the middle of a conversation with
somebody you're like half in on and then
you jerk off later and you're like yeah
I care about
any of this anymore yeah I'm gonna go
write a book it's too much work yeah
it's like all head it's like left brain
stuff and you really want it right brain
feelings and it's like what I have to do
this essay yeah it's like you have to
think about each response and how long
that takes it's such a long time and
some people it's just never they're
never going to want to meet up or just
enjoy
yeah yeah
which is true too like even if it is
going good it's like
if it lasts like if it if if you're
talking for like a week or longer I feel
like you there's no chance it's just
been too long it's just been like the
excitement's gone
well yeah I mean you got to do it if you
enjoy it like I feel like the best way
to do it this is like purely armchair
quarterbacking hypothesizing because
I've actually never done it but it's
like just respond to people that you
want to respond it should be easy and if
you're easy thoughts and just
instinctual responses are What She Likes
then it's probably not a good match
but then it's like you're gonna just say
whatever and oh whatever [ __ ] them they
don't like me I'm gonna find someone
else and then you never improve so
you're right a little bit of both you
have to like constantly like critique
yourself and like try to be better but
like texting is like such a weird thing
to do
I used to think that I hated texting and
that well I did and then until like the
last couple years I've noticed like
don't call me
just text me yeah I I don't like it I
don't think that I'm reverting to like
yeah or or converting to the new ways
rather I mean I either want all of it or
none of it I don't want to have like a
FaceTime thing even though I FaceTime my
girl all the time but uh just
hypothetically I'd rather see you in
person than to do this fake scene thing
uh so yeah I mean most meetings can be
an email most phone calls can be a text
but if you enjoy the emotional benefits
of a phone call that's the only reason
to call someone it's not to convey
information
uh because you can do that with the text
it's like if you enjoy talking and
hearing their voice and you know like uh
hearing the emotional context behind
what they're saying as well then it's uh
better but uh yeah I mean I think it's
uh you gotta
you you I think most most things can be
a text message I get annoyed when
someone calls me and they could have
just texted me certain things I think
are better for I like the voice memo
aspect now because like
you know texting is
sometimes you don't want the call but
also texting is not enough so you can
just say it send it real quick and get
your tone and uh you know your your
yeah
typing because then you're like let me
delete that it needs another word yeah
because sometimes like you know
just communicating verbally is like the
natural pauses in your voice or the
inflection it tells More Than Just Words
anyway yeah so you convey more
information yeah
yeah I mean I like talking to women
because I like hearing their voice but
if a man's voice makes me feel good then
I feel weird about it yeah like uh like
um is there anyone in particular like is
there a podcast or that like do you like
Joe Rogan's Voice or
yeah I love Joe Rogan's voice yeah
under pressure no pressure to say that
yeah no I love his voice
um but yeah I mean I love uh I love
getting calls from Joe because it's like
I it's someone I respect and it's like
oh my God like you know presidents and
[ __ ] leaders of Industry would love
to be able to talk to Joe Rogan and just
doing it for free yeah
um so there's that but that's not that's
not enough but like enough to like feel
yeah that's kind of gross to get
enjoyment out of that it's just like I
like hearing from him because he's like
been really nice to me and he's like
really wise and in someone at respect
he's like my mentor and he can tell me a
lot for sure I mean also I think it's
true like there's another aspect to it
that that's natural and normal it's like
a sense of reward for you I mean you put
in a lot of work to get where you're at
you know and then just the fact that
like that feeling you get but when
you're talking to him it's just like
it's like uh it's rewarding I mean it
just reminds you of the work that you
put in and why you know why you know
right but if I'm thinking about that
when I'm talking to him I'm not gonna
have like a natural conversation yeah
well don't think about it while you're
talking to just be aware of it well yeah
just like fascinated that this guy it's
like you know Babe Ruth to me I listened
to him forever like a lot of people did
and now I get to talk to him since it's
awesome I love it yeah man well I'm
super proud of you dude you've been
killing it and just since and I mean I
know they played on me much but it is
it's cool it's cool thank you yeah I
appreciate it it's cool to see genuinely
it's cool to see your [ __ ] thanks
surprising yeah it's better than people
being like you suck yeah I hate you
you're gonna fall
so yeah every time I hear a compliment
I'm like well it could have been way
worse yeah
yeah people are gonna always have
something negative to say yeah but I
mean I feel like I'm really blessed and
that I get too much positive like I
could handle a lot more negative but
yeah mostly it's positive so yeah I'm I
have a good mix right now I think I'm
Gonna Keep it this way yeah you're in a
position too now where you're gonna get
a lot of Yes Men or yes people around
you and like so that's I think what
you're talking about where like you can
handle more negative maybe but it's all
right I don't want too much positive
yeah because then it's just hot air no
constructive no improving no room for
yeah yeah 100 percent
what do you what do you think about is
is uh
Josh Club coming up soon or yeah has it
been pushed he said on his podcast that
is coming out in January
so that's really soon hell yeah uh yeah
I'm excited uh how's the uh Austin scene
like I heard from a couple people that
like it's not as uh
exciting as it was in the beginning like
it's sort of like lost a little bit of
its luster like people like oh [ __ ] this
is gonna be a grind it's not like the
instant success that they were looking
for yeah I've heard people talking about
that too and I think the point that I
heard
uh is like it seems talking to comedians
who came to Austin from another comedy
scene like Boston or something and
um
they say that it just it seems in Austin
like it's it's a little more clicky like
hey I do this show and uh I'll put you
on if you put me on your show yeah and
then also yeah that's true the like
rearranging of the of the list is also
something that I think favoritism yeah
it's like there's been like cause like
there's some mics that you'll do you'll
have to like they'll have like this
catch to it it's like get here and the
first 20 people to pick a number that's
your order and then everyone else after
that is like you know first come first
serve but that first 20 people is going
to be changed it's gonna I've done that
before and I was like number 14 and I
timed it perfectly I showed up to the
spot and I got there like 20 minutes
before I should have went up and it was
an hour and 45 minutes before I went up
after that I was like I wonder what Mike
you're talking about I have no idea yeah
well I don't want to say too much more I
think I can make a guess and get lucky
yeah you got lucky I think you can get
lucky yeah yeah that's just one of the
ones well that mic is notorious for that
but yeah I mean uh it is Texas it is all
about who you know and that's kind of
what the vibe of this place is but yeah
I think that there's a really positive
vibe here that I haven't felt in other
scenes I agree with you on that there's
definitely a positive to it and it seems
like it's a lot of like no one's Out Of
Reach kind of a thing like everyone is
yeah available to you know it just
depends on if they want to talk to you
or not yeah it's not like a snobby class
thing it's more like a personality thing
but yeah I mean I think a lot of people
moved here from all over the country so
everyone is different like there's gonna
be a lot of clicks because there's like
people from Boston like a lot of people
from Boston moved here there's like
people from Detroit like Genevieve
Clinton and Marcus Oland and then like
people who are from Texas or Houston
like Liz Splat or uh Dallas or wherever
she's from and then like you know people
who are here here in Austin who'd like
or a separate entity they're they're not
even like it doesn't even seem like
they're we're in the same scene
there's a large it's a large scene here
though too because I'm seeing Comics
that like I've never come across before
that have just been doing comedy in
Austin for years I do into this mic
or not well as a show not a mic rather
and uh the whole lineup the only person
I knew was Dylan Sullivan and there was
like four or five other great comedians
that have been doing comedy in Austin so
you just don't see them I guess at like
the open mics and stuff and and like or
those clubs rather as much and uh so
it's cool to see I I like the diversity
aspect of it I think that that should
yeah contribute yeah it's great yeah
yeah you need everyone you get a richer
palette if you mix everyone's colors
together right uh yeah I think it's
great I think it's just unfortunate that
sometimes there can be clicks but like
you know it makes sense because like I
don't really get along with some of the
people that are like a little too riffy
and they don't get along with me but I
mean we can still hang out and talk and
stuff right it's just like I'd rather
hang out with you know fellow Shih Tzus
yeah I hear you there's I mean there's
there's an aspect of I think a necessary
aspect to clicks but like I think you
know
there comes a point where like if you
want to run a successful show you need
to take that buddy element out of it and
organize a good show and stick to it
because yeah you know I mean I like to
think that I'm objective and who I think
is funny but I know I'm just subjective
it's like whoever I like yeah I'm
probably going to be more partial too
yeah I mean comedy is very subjective
it's a lot about likability like if you
like them it's easier to laugh yeah yeah
for sure I mean you're right someone can
do the same bit
and bomb and the next person can do the
same bit and murder yeah you're right
likability is a big part of it yeah
because if I don't like someone I don't
want them to get any positive approval
even if I think it's funny yeah like I
don't want to encourage them if I know
that they're gonna use this laugh to
feed their ego yeah that's like the
biggest thing I look for in cop
comedians is humility like I can't laugh
at someone who's too arrogant
yeah like someone who doesn't who's not
like because then you're not a real
person it's like who are you you're just
you're being fake yeah constantly you're
blowing yourself up yeah and then who
knows what I'm encouraging it might
become a serial killer Jeffrey D dude
the old D string how long is that show
uh 10 episodes I think roughly 10 hours
10 hours of Jeffrey Dahmer it's pretty
good uh it's good it's good and then I
saw the whole thing I saw the whole
thing but the but episodes like six
or maybe episodes seven eight and nine
there's like three episodes I Loosely
watched right towards the end it kind of
slowed down
the first half though
yeah with the build up yeah where he's
just marking well episode one is all
about and I don't think this gives
anything away but episode one they do a
really good job of like I heard it's
just it's like it's like a spoiler at
the beginning yeah so to speak I mean
well everyone knows they start they
start yeah we wouldn't know about him at
all right they start with that that
episode one is the
the Asian
no he's not Asian not the first not the
one he got caught on oh it was a black
dude who was it that uh escaped and the
police found him and then they returned
him back to the serial killer his 14
year old boy who uh that was Jeffrey D
that was Jeffrey D and uh there was this
14 year old boy I don't know his
ethnicity but his brother
was caught before him and he
acknowledges it in the like in the room
because Jeffrey Dahmer talks like he he
entices them with money he's like I'll
take I just want to take pictures
just want to do some pictures I'll give
you 50 bucks or 100 bucks and they're
like okay and then this kid says like
you don't know who I am and he's like
no and he's like
my brother went to the police he ran
away you did you try to do this to him
and and then Jeff he's like he's lying
blah blah blah but like the kid stays
because his family needs the money
and he ends up lobotomizing this kid
with a [ __ ] just drill and a drill
bit and then that's when the kid like
makes his tries to make his Escape but
he can't articulate words and then the
cops are like
uh
he the also back then like being gay was
like cops didn't want to deal with it
they were just like yeah marginalized
people they're forgotten right don't get
the same law enforcement that the rest
of us get right so Jeffrey Dahmer was
just like this is my boyfriend I have
pictures of him and he did take pictures
like 30 minutes before and so the cops
come in and he shows the pictures and I
guess that was enough for the cops to be
like look it's just weird gay [ __ ] we
handled it like that's what they say in
the yeah and the they're like I don't
want to get too deep into it yeah
homophobia is not it makes you bad at
your job you gotta love dicks unless
you're not gonna be a good policeman
yeah I think it's uh sad that people are
into it I think it's a sign of like we
don't like each other and we're like
like how would I [ __ ] people up like I
know it's coming we feel a little
anxiety we're like looking at each other
like would I be able to take this guy
yeah and it's like we're just getting
ready for the moment where we have to
just start murking people yeah he
literally does the same move to all of
them he makes them a drink
literally the same and then they drink
it and they get uh they pass out yeah
it's powerful so yeah woman struck
woman's weapon a woman's weapon I uh
yeah it's it's a cool it's a cool little
thing I mean it's cool to see I also
agree with you though I think in a
different way it's kind of [ __ ] the
whole documentary because it
gives you sympathy
for old Jeffrey D dude hi because you
you see his upbringing like the parents
uh like they do a really good job yeah
the actors in it are all really good so
that's another thing too it's like every
actor is brilliant and so what was
[ __ ] up about his childhood
so his mom
uh he's the oldest he has two other
siblings I believe in any way his his
mom had postpartum depression whenever
she had him and the doctors
uh cure was a bunch of pills at one
point I guess she was on 26 different
pills so she got hooked and they were
all like opioids or whatever and uh
so she became distant and addicted and
uh attempted suicide just wasn't happy
the father was very distant he was never
home and uh so then I heard your throat
do something weird yeah yeah he's
bubbling up I'm getting the dragon growl
dude thinking about this drugged out
mother yeah so anyway it's just a
neglect Factor so the mother kept
leaving him the dad kept leaving him and
uh and at one point he's like telling
his dad
something's wrong with me and the dad
doesn't really listen the dad the dad's
uh
the dad's solution is like
I'll send you to Ohio State I'll pay for
your first semester and uh he just
avoids everything and then
at one point uh Jeffrey's living on his
own for three months his dad already
left divorced the mom the mom was
supposed to stay at the house the mom
ends up leaving and then Jeffrey's alone
for like three months and that's when he
does his first
killing but it's just like it's just
sympathy and the fact that like you know
what if it was done differently in his
upbringing maybe it would have been yeah
it doesn't sound too horrible I mean
yeah yeah I mean it's like sad and it's
like scary because like if that's all it
takes to make a serial killer yeah it's
like we could be making a bunch of them
yeah also I mean you just gotta kind of
watch it I think the actors being so
good are is also like
just they're they're great at their jobs
so they make you feel what you're
supposed to feel yeah and uh yeah but
the argument on that is like people are
saying that if
they're talking about boycotting it and
if they and if to keep it up the
solution that people would be happy with
is give that money to the victims
families yeah
it doesn't sound far off the Netflix
money
yeah I mean I think like uh serial
killers I think are like an American
phenomenon like other countries do it
but we have like the best and the most
yeah and I think it's like a culture
thing because like everyone here came
from another culture and we don't have
like a shared culture like we're we're
not like Melting Pot
estonians right uh so we don't we don't
have like this kinship with each other
and also I think uh our welfare system
isn't very good so I think like a lot of
people grow up in horrible situations
where people are struggling to survive
and that could
make it more likely that you're gonna
murder someone do crime and if you have
like a traumatic childhood yeah if your
mother has like stress and you're in the
womb then you grow up you come out of
the womb like a little jumpy and [ __ ] so
I don't think that helps
but uh yeah I mean I I don't think
that's a good thing that we're all like
watching this and being like wow yeah
this is crazy but I think it's like
natural almost like because I think it's
natural to want to like you see people
around all around you and they're
cutting you off in traffic and they're
not like really your friend they're sort
of your enemy they're sort of your
opponents and they're like what if I did
the worst things and like you know
really
uh one over my opponents in the best way
possible yeah
but I don't know I think that's the true
test to see if someone is a serial
killer or not put them in a road rage
incident see what they see how they
handle it
I've never been or they've never had
more violent thoughts than in a road
rage incident dude yeah or just avoid
road rage incidents so that you don't
Spike everyone's you know cortisol
levels yeah every day five times a day I
try to avoid the road just to avoid road
rage and pollution and like danger it's
like that's the reason why you get road
rage just because it's dangerous it's
like you could die you cut me off and I
had to slam with my brakes I almost hit
you and now I want to really hit you
yeah well we're in these exoskeletons
that go 70 miles per hour and they're
made out of steel and now we have to
embody the personality and emotions of a
[ __ ] robotic uh internal combustion
engine gas guzzling thing it's like not
how we're supposed to be we're not
supposed to be cars we're supposed to be
humans it must be horses
uh horses are better yeah horses are
cool it kind of makes you cocky though
if you're on a horse if you know how to
ride one well and then you see a human
on foot yeah do you like do you spit on
them or what do you
I don't know what are those horse cops
do those horse cops always look afraid
the horse cops look afraid yeah
I think those uh
the horses look like they're ready to
[ __ ] bite you though yeah those are
like war horses yeah they're ready they
don't give a [ __ ] they'll [ __ ] throw
you out of the way by humans but a
plastic bag that might freak them out
do you think of like
it would be a terrible idea just to like
pop a paper brown paper bag in front of
a horse you know that's our strategy
yeah that's how you throw their uh their
equilibrium off I don't know yeah what
what do horses hate
I don't know what is like their Jeffrey
Dahmer
like I think like a four-legged wolf
type thing just crouching I think that
would freak them out just like a ready
to pounce wolf yeah yeah just
instinctively maybe do you think it's
like a mouse too like you think a mouse
or something or do you think like like
elephants hate mice I guess do you think
horses hate mice do you think it's the
same yeah I think it's like how some
people hate needles because of a small
and pointy it is yeah I think some
people or some horses would be like oh
[ __ ] that thing can like crawl into my
butthole yeah yeah and eat me out from
the inside yeah like an ant eating an
elephant because that's the one thing
that could kill an elephant
as if you're small enough like the other
one would be really big or really small
that you want to be in the middle so
like like
trillion ants covering an elephant he
doesn't stand a chance yeah he rolls
around maybe but they're still going to
be there yeah you can run away that'd be
a terrible death dude yeah they're
inside you
like what is me if these ants are inside
me are these ants me now or are you the
ants what if they're controlling me yeah
oh they're controlling me that's so
crazy that he was lobotomizing people
it's wild yeah I think the also the
interest people is just like no one
really knew that much about Jeffrey
Dahmer other than like
it kind of romanticizes it I think a
little bit like giving aspect to his
upbringing and like his thoughts or do
you think it's gonna make serial killers
or do you think it's gonna
be like an inoculation like a vaccine
let me try some chicken about it
this is how I used solve problems in
Alabama yeah you just try some chicken
goddamn this math problems hard let me
let me eat some chicken about it
um
what was the question again before I
uh if you
or Jeffrey Dahmer oh do you think the
Jeffrey Dahmer thing is going to make
sure the Netflix show is gonna make
serial killers or deter them
I think that it has a good chance to uh
do both probably more of making them
though I mean
I mean it's like whenever you see the
movies where it's like a robber Robs a
bank and then he pours bleach on
everything that you know like it teaches
you how to get rid of the evidence
Jeffrey Dahmer teaches you how to you
know
go to gay bars and Drug
dudes and lobotomize them I don't know
but also we're in a different time
it was that was
um 70 no 80s and all the 80s I guess a
91 was people are Dumber back then they
thought that everyone was their friend
they were hitchhiking like idiots yeah
would you have you ever hitchhiked no I
haven't either I had a buddy that that
lived by it he uh he was like from
Montana and just said that he just he
used to log and he's gonna die by it too
yeah I don't know if I could do it I
think it's relatively safe
yeah I think it's one of those things
though that like you
the the person stopping should be
concerned to pick up but also you
hitchhiking should be concerned like you
should do like a little you should vet
them a little bit like
yeah dude dude diligence yeah were you
like what kind of questions would you
ask though like if you were a hitchhiker
to determine the safety I don't think
it's about the questions I think it's
about The Vibes and the way they look at
you how long they hold eye contact uh
what emotions they possess yeah
they got a smile like mine they're up to
no good just like come on in yeah get in
the get in the back they want you to
feel a certain way if they let you have
your own emotions or if they're trying
to make you feel something
there's just a mic that's picking it up
or is it loud as [ __ ] I think it's a
combo but you also have these are good
mics these sure sm7bs yeah at least I'm
sure sm7b's these are
good mics but we're picking up airplane
noises yeah what do you you uh do you
like the windows in here because you
could cover those with like some dynomat
I mean they exist I don't want to deny
the room if it's right that would be
intrinsic qualities right that would be
the the trade-off you wouldn't have
Windows but the dynomat would help with
sounds like that
yeah this this room is a little Echo it
was a lot more echoey without these
things
yeah you can do
um a couple other like silly Corners
they're called bass traps
put uh it's just like Styrofoam like
triangle pieces and those do a lot too
but you're right I mean audio treating
your room is a necessary step for yeah
yeah should I get those black things
with the have the ribs on it that's what
the that's what those bass traps are
they look like that
um
show you an example of one
but uh yeah man I like your uh I like
your spot here it's better than um your
old your last place without AC
that was only for a month
dude they look like this
so they'll just fit in the corner but
they do a lot uh surprisingly a lot for
the Echo and they're yeah I like this
table because we could play Katan here
[ __ ] yeah dude this is a giant ass table
for Katan we probably only need like
that much space for Katan so there's a
um you have the expansion pack right
yeah I was at Target the other day and
there's is there like a double expansion
pack or is there another game similar
there's a bunch of different expansions
okay I almost bought something and gave
it to you I didn't know what you had
though it confused me it wasn't called
Katan though but it was like the same
like artwork it was like Katan but like
like
I don't know I don't know what it's
called it's probably a completely
different game it's probably a risk yeah
it's clue uh because guess who do you
remember guess who
yeah it was a great game yeah little
pop-ups and you put him down yeah
yeah is your guy black
yeah is your guy uh is your person look
like they could be lgbtqia plus
half the board can go down I would like
I came up with like a bunch of questions
just to [ __ ] with the people and one of
them was like does your person like long
walks on the beach
yeah yeah that's that's subjective
though too right I'm sure
yeah hey answer that yeah it's like I
don't know I think so and then you like
then you have to be like oh this person
does not look like he likes Beach walks
you basically take everyone with red
hair off the board though they don't
like sun yeah but what if they don't
know that about gingers and they're like
yeah that's a smile what if they got
sunscreen or something you know yeah
it's a fun game it's like all
probability so I bet there's like the if
you Google it there's like the perfect
questions to ask
to get the answer the quickest you think
that's cheating
no I think that's math yeah but I mean
I'm not arguing that like it's
information and from you should if you
have access to information you shouldn't
remember it I think is uh what Albert
Einstein said I think that's true in a
lot of ways yeah like I don't need to
memorize the Pythagorean theorem if I
can if I can Google it but yeah
also the game is about like your
intelligence and strategy so by copying
how intelligent is it to use the most
intelligent strategy that you found
yeah well intelligent to be like no I
gotta use my gut and my emotions to
figure this out well it's like a Rubik's
Cube like if you if you Google how to
solve it did you really solve it
right
or you just [ __ ] followed you
connected the dots but it's easy to be
like oh there's a correct answer for
Rubik's Cube not a lot of people are
gonna be like oh there's a correct
answer for guess who they're gonna be
like no I got this yeah so it takes a
certain amount of intelligence to be
like mathematically there should be a
way to eliminate half
each answer to get the quickest
because if that's the that's the most
you can that's the best way to do it do
you think it would be a list of
questions different for each person or
do you think it would be a general list
depending on the board it depends on
what what the board is yeah
like if half the people have green eyes
then asking about green eyes would be
the most effective but I bet they make
it so that it's not that easy it's all
racially ambiguous
I have guessed who we should maybe
I bet it's online you like an online
version yeah so we don't have to set it
up yeah something's fun about flicking
them down though yeah that was a large
part of it
and then you bump into it and you have
to start all over the worst you're like
[ __ ] it's like all my work yeah all my
due diligence yeah out the window yeah
what would uh outside of Katan what's
another board game that you enjoyed or
used to enjoy
uh
uh I don't know most board games suck
Shoots and Ladders it's pretty pretty
good it's all a Chance
Kitchen ladders is a good one yeah if
you can go up and back
Monopoly though that's a classic
Monopoly is great but it's unplayable it
like takes forever and no one ever
finishes it either someone yeah either
someone gets over it and like oh [ __ ] I
gotta do we should call the podcast I
forgot I have chicken in the oven okay
you wanna uh you can't pause the stream
can you I can yeah
gotta pause it sure
commercial break all right let's uh let
me pull something up
maybe we can run that ad while you're
doing a commercial break oh yeah the I
don't know how this works yeah oh we're
on YouTube ads inserted I guess we
figured out later I uh
I haven't finished
um
any uh
I haven't put any Clips in there from
Ian yeah but uh
royalty free videos
I don't know what to put on
can you do uh on these streams like
these podcasts can you play music like
uh on YouTube you know what I mean I
think I can I've got a music video or
something gets demonetized and sometimes
they're like [ __ ] don't do that no I
yeah it well there's like weird gray
area you can do it for like a certain
length of time but like
also if you there's ways to get around
it like if you slow it down or
oh gosh whatever I'll just put this up
yeah do that that's good
singer forever
display
sure
um all right see you guys be BRB
and we're back welcome back what a night
what a day we had yeah
um so are you doing any shows coming up
um
no I don't think so I had I got invited
to do hyenas in Dallas
um I was thinking about uh
doing that I don't have a confirmed date
but uh I kind of I was doing that show
and it kind of took a lot of my time and
I've kind of uh
and I've kind of put it on the back
burner uh the show because it I wasn't
focusing on what I wanted to focus on
you know my stand-up and other things
and so I'm just getting back into the
you know the groove I've been writing
the whole time I still got I have like
15 minutes of new material that I need
to fledge out but uh
that's fun it's exciting when you have
new stuff
yeah yeah I'm excited about it it's just
uh
I like to do I feel like Dallas everyone
goes to Dallas but not everyone goes not
like it's more popular I think than
Houston more established maybe they just
have like I think they have more
established comedy clubs yeah
like we have the creek in the cave but
like it's not that the hyenas and the uh
improv there exactly everyone knows
those Brands like at least improv yeah
and
uh you know what we're getting now we're
getting Cap City I mean it'll change
soon I think the dynamic will shift
especially when Joe's show or Club opens
yeah I think that you know that's he
wants to be the mothership right of
Comedy or something like yeah how he
puts it I think it will happen 100 yeah
you you were telling me about that venue
though right it's gonna be like two
rooms or no yeah hell yeah yeah
it'll be like The Comedy Store they have
three rooms there but yeah I love The
Comedy Store have you been yeah it's
such a good vibe yeah I love The Comedy
Store I I was doing comedy right before
the pandemic started oh yeah you lived
in L.A I started uh I did it at the haha
a couple times and then um I never did
the comedy comedy store but I went to a
lot of shows I just was surrounding
myself with it you know while I was
there which is I think
at least my approach to most things like
whenever I'm starting something new or
like you know I like to surround myself
with it so I can understand
yeah you know everything like the
language the Norms the yeah so you can
imbibe it be a part of it and be
successful with it you know yeah yeah I
like to contribute not [ __ ] shake up
yeah too much anyway that's the best way
to succeed individually is to contribute
it's like selfish to be generous
yeah well in a way yeah I mean you
you think it's selfish to be generous I
think if you're good at being generous
then
it's like you should look at it as like
helping you and that will whatever you
have to do to do more of it
I think it's fine even if you're doing
it for like selfish reasons if you can
keep doing it then you eventually going
to do it for the right reasons I think
finding a balance for sure is you know
the The Sweet Spot obviously but like
there's I mean anything anytime you're
taking time for yourself you're being
selfish and I think it's necessary to be
selfish sometimes like even if you're
just working on your exercise routine
yeah I think it's important to make
individuals awesome and then the whole
thing will be better a thousand percent
yeah but I think so much room like you
don't need there's too much room for
everybody like why do I need to [ __ ]
be alone and yeah why do I have to
sacrifice large parts of my personality
for the greater good when there's plenty
of people we don't need what are we
doing that we need so much everyone to
pitch in for but I think it's there's
too much selfishness that's the problem
I don't think it's that people are too
generous and they're too selfless I
think the problem is that like overall
the problem with the world and what we
more of his more generosity but yeah
like individually like you know maybe
individually you could be more selfish
yeah I agree with that I'm not
advocating for selfishness but I'm
saying uh in the generosity aspect of it
I mean finding that balance but I mean
there's also stages I think you should
go through to to you shouldn't just
start off selfish and only be selfish
like maybe you get to that point after
you've contributed and and given and
then you know now it's like okay I'm
gonna take a beat take a second and
be selfish for a second yeah
it's good I mean it's not bad to be
selfish it's just if you are only
selfish then it's bad but yeah it's good
to indulge and like be like I'm gonna
just do whatever I want to do
yeah I think that also doesn't give you
a leg to stand on like communicating
wise like if I go like when I first
moved to Austin I went to you know I was
at the mics every night and like the
Banana Phone and stuff like that and
like you don't like if you don't know
anybody in the scene
at least for me I'm not comfortable to
just be my true authentic self because
everyone has all of these backstories
and and you know experiences with each
other and and you know they can go back
and forth and and you're just this new
guy that everyone's watching like you
can't
there's more pressure on you I think so
I think the approach is to like
find common ground and be a human and
like just you know try to contribute
where you can and show your value I
guess yeah
I like contributing
at the end of the day that's what it's
all about like even if like you want to
be the best stand-up comedian and a rock
star and have everyone love you like
what you really want is to impart Upon A
lot of people value
whether it's emotional or information
and then for them to love you for it
because you provide the value because
you're doing something good for the
community like even in our most selfish
desires it's like about helping others
and I think that's beautiful like people
want to be rock stars and [ __ ] and movie
stars because they want to perform in
front of people and give them the
emotion that they feel is so strong and
so unique to them right
whether it is or not who knows yeah
yeah I mean whether it is or not that's
how you
that's the everyone feels like their
emotions are awesome because they're
feeling it and of course it feels
awesome for you yeah it doesn't mean
everyone not for the listeners all the
time yeah some people I don't yeah I've
seen that uh
that hand play out where like you just
see a comic who's like not like
not even necessarily new to it but just
like terrible it just been but doesn't
change their approach or anything like
that and they're
it's just uh like you gotta have the
self-growth
at some point like I think you know yeah
change your view change your thought
process or whatever yeah
you gotta yeah you gotta improve
yourself you can't just be so satisfied
with yourself all the time
who made that shirt that's sick dude I
don't know
where can they buy it I don't know the
proceeds go to Hans Kim or is it forget
who made this please message me I forget
yeah so sorry that's just sick dude it's
a badly photoshopped I feel like the
fact that it's badly photoshopped
actually adds to the value I don't I
don't think it's uh I think the filter
over it makes it
the bad Photoshop acceptable yeah
because it looks kind of like digitally
3D glitched yeah
yeah
it looks your little 8-bit yeah looks
sort of like an Instagram thing looks
like it was taken on a flip phone yeah
that's great
have you thought about doing uh your own
line of merch like I mean I know you got
yours I know you got your things but
like graphic tees like that like like
maybe yeah you have your what all kind
of merch do you have I know you have
those leather stamped stickers the key
chains yeah do you have um graphic tees
or stickers I have
um
graphic tees no not really
you can get like uh you could go to town
with that like you could do like all
kind of Pop Culture you could put your
face on Pablo Escobar's mugshots I don't
want to like spend time doing that [ __ ]
I'd rather just lay in my hammock yeah I
got a hammock yeah do you make good
money off your merch or yeah I never
count it right I just do it and then I
stuff it in my wallet yeah
I uh I have no idea but I'm selling them
for more than I'm buying them so I'm
sure I'm making money which is the key
yeah it's just like if I'm gonna be
concentrated on that I'm gonna become a
little shopkeeper a little yeah maybe
you should yeah I don't think that would
be something you should focus your
energy on as far as like designing the
graphics and stuff but you know Shopify
or something like that you know they do
it for you yeah you know to a certain
yeah one of those things where they have
a warehouse and then you just it's made
to order whatever right you have to do
no story take a giant percentage of it
yeah but if you're not counting you know
what I mean it's just yeah
yeah I mean because you could do like
seasonal you could just do it like or
quarterly or like which I guess would be
seasonal but like uh you could just have
like this is the line of Hans Kim
graphic tees for the next six months and
then that way you don't have to think
about it for six months or you don't
have to pay someone to design again for
six months or whatever yeah I could do
that it would just be a live stream
money yeah I don't think it's selling
out you know it's also like
you could consider it like you know this
is the
2022 tour drop I'm doing these graphic
yeah designs for if you got this shirt
it means you were a fan back then type
of a thing yeah I don't know something
to think about I'd love to
yeah
yeah what do you like to do you like to
uh
you like to do like a lot of uh
intricate things like production and
like yeah arranging things I do a lot of
video editing I do a lot of content
creating like I make commercials I just
did a commercial uh well not really
commercial I think I sent it to you for
the LA Rams
um I designed a little splash yeah and
uh it's like a little Eight Second clip
that's gonna play and during the games
and it's just stuff like that's cool
um but I it's not what I want to do
forever it's just something that I'm
good at and
um uh it's opened a lot of opportunities
open a lot of doors but I like doing
anything creative like graphic design I
even like writing like I want to write a
book one day a couple a couple even yeah
I have a an idea for I hesitate to say
it on here but uh I think it's a pretty
cool idea I like sci-fi it's like no
it's like a short story book so it's
like a book with like
12 to 15 different short stories in
there yeah you have ideas nice I'll tell
you one of them
um so for example so like the theme is
this is a working title but it would be
like what if and so each story would uh
it would be about a real person so let's
say
uh Genghis Khan
right so he's one of the guys that have
a a idea about and so the first half of
the story would be the real facts the
actual you know leading up to it up to
the moment the what if moment like what
if it's like a glorious bastards what if
something did different yeah and then
like so for example like
you can go deep with the Genghis Khan
one because uh Russia wasn't
Russia they were like the tartars there
were a bunch of different countries and
then when Genghis Khan was coming down
he was taken over China and he was
headed towards Europe
all of the countries in Russia banded
together and then formed the USSR
and that was because of Genghis Khan and
because they thought that separately
they were too weak together though they
had a chance and so you know from there
uh that the Russian the Cold War the
space race all of that stuff so it's 800
years earlier yeah but like what would
happen so that would be like the what if
so like what if Genghis Khan
[ __ ] created settled down with one of
his rape victims and didn't keep keep
the charge going so did and then Russia
never becomes Russia
what would you know what would it be so
you just have you could just take it 100
different directions but it's stories
like that yeah and I got something about
like JK Rowling uh JFK
that's cool bunch of stuff just ideas
yes things just creative [ __ ] you know
it's yeah and uh
so that kind of stuff I just like being
creative yes yeah I just like being I
like using my brain yeah idea man over
here I guess yeah the good thing about
books is that it's so cheap all it takes
is time and energy and so crazy how
difficult something so
you know low budget can be right and
it's anyone can publish nowadays before
50 years ago you had to sign with a big
publishing deal and
uh now Amazon you could just publish
anything you could publish a child's
book yeah and if it's good it'll sell if
it's good it'll sell but if not it's
still published and it's out there and
it's existing yeah it's like uh your
sales don't matter hypocrisy yeah as far
as you know whether the content exists
or not it doesn't doesn't matter what
your sales are so that's cool to books
you know have you ever thought about
writing a book yeah I want to I read
books growing up but I haven't been
really good at writing so I don't know
it's like trying to learn you know like
how to play basketball
and then being like I should be in the
NBA like it seems like a lot but it
seems like writing is like accessible to
a lot of people because it's like people
who haven't written
uh get best sellers because just because
they're interesting people
but that yeah if you want to get good at
it obviously you have to do it for a
while
what would you write about you think
if you you know had to help like because
there's people who help you ride it
obviously but yeah if you had you know
no worries no stressors on like the how
it's getting done right some fiction
about some person trying to do their
best
someone giving it their all yeah
yeah because that's that's kind of stuff
I like to read like Aragorn
I didn't read it's like a fantasy thing
it's like uh the chosen one oh wow this
guy is so gifted and he has all the
power and he didn't expect it he's just
a normal person just the Underdog Story
huh yeah yeah the hero's journey which
is cool yeah I think uh yeah I mean
there's no shortage of like that stuff
can
win every time you know what I mean it's
just a matter of it's like your own spin
on it and what you choose to emphasize
and what part of it you want to focus on
yeah finding your your twist yeah or
whatever on the story to make it you
know your own thing I had a
uh I don't wanna I guess I'll I have
another uh I'll just say I don't give a
[ __ ]
um I have another idea for a movie that
would uh it could be a movie it could be
a story but like I was watching uh
American Horror Story and I got this
idea
um the stay-at-home dad therapist that
has his clients come in you know he's
very successful uh
well
in 1912 there was this real story called
The h family or the H house or something
like that and it was a house where this
family moved into and all of this weird
[ __ ] started happening like people were
seeing things the kids the The Nanny
like they had they had staff they were
seeing things and hearing things and
like they were convinced it was haunted
well
um
turns out that they had a gas leak and
they were all carbon monoxide poisoned
and it was just enough to not kill him
but it was enough to cause the side
effects which are hallucinog
hallucinations and stuff so I had an
idea about a you know a story with like
combining that with like a stay-at-home
therapist and then like
kind of meets The Shining I guess the
family leaves maybe for a holiday or
something and the dad stays and
he the family gets better because they
they're not breathing in that carbon
monoxide anymore and the dad's still
there just stewing in it and then all
hell breaks loose or whatever when they
come back yeah when they come back the
dad she's just been
huffing it's been huffing dude yeah it's
been huffing away so I don't know I got
a just a bunch of yeah weird [ __ ] like
that that's great because then you don't
have to do that you can just write about
it and you can still go through the
emotions and your brain tricking
yourself into thinking that you did it
yeah
yeah yeah I don't know
um is it okay if we call it here yeah
man okay cool all right thanks for
listening guys yeah thanks for coming
out